اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تكشف ان دفاعات
اوكرانيا لن تتحمل القصف الروسيه بسبب نقص
الذخيره
حيه قربه
فني ايراني يتوجه الى الرياض خلال ايام
لمواصله استعدادات اعاده فتح السفاره
الايرانيه
اكثر من الف مستوطن اسرائيلي اقتحموا
باحات المسجد الاقصى على دفعات منذ صباح
اليوم
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا بملف تسريب وثائق
الشديده السريه تابعه للبنت الامريكي
اكتشف الصحيفه واشنطن استنادا الى هذه
الوثائق ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تواجه نقصا خطيرا في انظمه الدفاع الجوي
والذخائر واكدت الوثائق التي كشفت ان
قدرتها دفاع جوي متوسط المدى لحمايه الخط
الامامي ستنخفض بحلول الثالث والعشرين من
مايو الصحيفه قالت ان الوثائق المسربه
كشفت ايضا ان عدد انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي
يرسلها الغرب محدود ولا تستطيع تحمل القصف
الروسي الكبير كما اظهرت وجود نقص كبير في
الذخيره في القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وانه بدون تجديد مستمر ستنفذ المخزونات في
غضون ايام قليله هذا وكشفت ايضا بل كشف
مصدر مقرب من الرئيس الاوكراني شبكه سي ان
كشف ان اوكرانيا غيرت بالفعل بعض خططها
العسكريه بسبب تسريب وثائق البنتاجون
وكانت الوثائق المسربه كشفت ايضا في وقت
سابق ان اوكرانيا ستفشل في فرض دفاع جوي
فعال قريبا ما لم تحصل على ذخيره واسلحه
داعمه بشكل عاجل
في سياق اخر مشاهدينا لفت الحكومه
الفرنسيه صحه الانباء التي تحدثت عن وجود
جنود فرنسيين على الاراضي بل على الارض في
اوكرانيا ونقل صحيفه الاموات عن مكتب وزير
القوات المسلحه ان القوات الفرنسيه لا
تشاركوا باي شكل في العمليات الى جانب
اوكرانيا وفي وقت سابق كشف صحيفه
عن وثائق مسربه تحدثت عن فرقه عسكريه لا
تتجاوز المئه جندي تتكون من عسكريين
رسميين من دول الناتو بمن فيهم فرنسا تقوم
بمهام قتاليه نشطه في اوكرانيا
وفيما تعمل الولايات المتحده على تقييم اي
مخاطر قد تترتب على امنها القومي عن تسريب
الوثائق السريه تتعلق حسب معاونه وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه قالت المتحدثه باسم
البنتاجون سابينا سينج ان تعاونا يجري بين
مختلف الوكالات لتقييم تاثير تسريب هذه
الوثائق المصوره على الامن القومي لامريكا
وعلى حلفائها وشركائه ايضا
وكما ذكرنا مشاهدينا فيما تعمل الولايات
المتحده على تقييم اي مخاطر قد تترتب على
امنها القومي عن تسريب الوثائق السريه
تتعلق
بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه وثائق البنتاجون
المسربه كشفت مدى عمق اختراق الولايات
المتحده لاجهزه الامن والاستخبارات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه ايضا ما يمكن واشنطن
من تقييم مدى قوه اله الحرب الروسيه ومن
تحذير كياب بشان الضربات التي تخطط موسكو
لتنفيذها ايضا نتابع
الولايات المتحده تتبع عورات روسيا
العسكريه لتكشف عيوبها امام الجيش
الاوكراني
البانتاجون يخترق بعمق اجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات الروسيه وفق ما جاء في
الوثائق المسربه خطوه جعلت واشنطن قادره
على تحذير اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخططه
لها وتقديم تقييم لقوه اله الحرب الروسيه
ومنحتها فهما واسعا للتخطيط الروسي
وامكانيه تحذير حلفائها بشان عمليات موسكو
في المستقبل
الوثائق المسربه ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي
المتهاوي الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
بيانات اتاحت لو واشنطن نقل المعلومات
الحساسه من اجل الدفاع عن نفسها من خلال
تحديد توقيت الضربات واهدافها بدقه في
حاله يرثى لها هكذا قيم الامريكيون الجيش
الاوكراني وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الوثائق تفصل نقص المخصصه للدفاعات الجويه
لدى الجيش الاوكراني كما تناقش المكاسب
التي تحققها القوه الروسيه حول مدينه بخمو
الشرقيه
القاده السياسيون والعسكريون في اوكرانيا
لم يكونوا بمعزل عن اعين التجسس الامريكي
وفق الوثائق المسربه ايضا
تحليلات قالت ان هذه الوثائق بامكانها
الحاق ضرر حقيقي بالمجهود الحربي
الاوكراني ان استطاعت موسكو قطعه مصادر
المعلومات
البيانات اظهرت ايضا ان فاكنار تعمل بنشاط
لتهديد المصالح الامريكيه واحباط مشاريعها
في افريقيا ومناطق اخرى
احدى هذه الوثائق كشفت ان مسؤولين من
فاجنر التقوا سرا بجهات تركيه في فبراير
وبحثوا تهريب اسلحه ومعدات لاستعمالها في
اوكرانيا وفق ما نقلت صحيفه نيويورك
قالوا ان الوثائق تبدو صحيحه لكن ادخل
التعديلات على بعضها لعكس صوره افضل عن
الوضع الروسي لاسيما من خلال التقليل من
حجم الخسائر الروسيه بلال البجداني
العربيه
الوثائق المسربه من البانتاجون تكشف
معطيات صادمه
توقل امريكي كبير في الجهاز العسكري
الروسي والاوكراني
الوثائق اظهرت قدره واشنطن على تحذير
اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط لها من
روسيا وتقييم اله الحرب الروسيه
الوثائق ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي المتهاوي
الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
وتكشف نقل المعلومات الحساسه الكياف
للدفاع عن نفسها من خلال تحديد توقيت
الضربات واهدافها
الوثائق تظهر ان عملاء واشنطن يخترقون
تقريبا كل الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
مسؤول استخبارتي غربي قال ان التسريب مؤلم
وقد يحد من تبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
ومكيف مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد
البابا اهلا بك محمد بدايه كيف كانت اصداء
هذه التسريبات في الداخل الاوكراني وما
مدى القلق من تاثيرات سلبيه تطالخطط
اوكرانيا اضف على هذه التسريبات
نعم يعني كان لهذه التسريبات والوثائق
التي تم تسريبها اثرا كبيرا في اوكرانيا
هناك يعني رايين في اوكرانيا في الشارع
العام الاوكراني يعني الراي الاول او ما
يؤيدها الاكثر اكثريه الشعب الاوكراني هو
ان هذه الوثائق مزوره ولا صحه لها لا بل
هي مجرد محاوله روسيه لضرب يعني التعاون
الاوكراني خاصه في المجال الاستخباراتي
لان اوكرانيا تعتمد على المعلومات التي
تقدمها الدول الغربيه مثل الاستخبارات
البريطانيه مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحتى حلف الناتو للجيش
الاوكراني حول احداثيات تحركات الجيش
الروسي لذلك اوكرانيا هي بحاجه لهذا الدعم
الاستخبارات الذي يلعب دور كبير في تقدم
او في العمليات العسكريه حتى في الدفاع
الاوكراني خاصه عندما يكون هناك ضربات
جويه ويعني احدى الوثائق هي نشرت يعني
عمليه انتشار او او يعني ظهرت فيها عمليات
انتشار الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه التي
تاثرت بشكل كبير في بدايه الحرب وحتى عام
تحديدا كانت الدفاعات الجويه متوقفه عن
العمل بشكل كامل والان دفاعات الجويه تعمل
بطريقه نشطه جدا يعني لضرب الصواريخ
الروسيه التي تطلق على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الراي الثاني يعتبر ان هذه الوثائق هي
يعني وثائق صحيحه مسربه وتظهر الدور دور
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في خرق وهذا
نقرا ايجابيه تنزل اليها اوكرانيا في خرج
الاستخبارات الروسيه حتى في خرج الكريم
بحد ذاته ومنها ومن كان يتداول في بشكل
كبير في اوكرانيا حول يعني موعد الغزل
الروسي لاوكرانيا حيث ان في اوكرانيا لم
يعني لا احد يصدق ان روسيا ستغزو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولكن صدقت المعلومات التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى ان
بوتين كذب هذه المعلومات ولكن على حقيقه
الواقع كان هناك غزو وصدقت المعلومات
الغربيه هناك رايين في اوكرانيا هذين
الرايين متوازيين ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا
تؤ ثر حسب وز الاوكرانيه هذه الوثائق لن
تؤثر على طبيعه العمليات في يعني في شرق
لكن محمد يعني هذه تسريبات ايضا يعني هي
عموما بشكل عام وضعت الولايات المتحده في
موقف محرج مع دون عده من بينها اوكرانيا
هناك التقارير تتحدث عن ان اوكرانيا اصلا
متردده في تقديم او امداد الولايات
المتحده ببعض المعلومات الحساسه عن موقفي
جيشها الميداني هل يتوقع ان تكون هناك
مراجعه لنوعيه معلومات المقدمه من
اوكرانيا الى واشنطن عفوا على هذه
التسريبات
يعني بحسب ما نعلمه من طبيعه الجيش
الاوكراني هناك تكتم كثير وكما ذكر
يعني امين عم مجلس الامن والدفاع
الاوكراني ان طبيعه ان هناك يعني مثلا
موعد الهجوم والمضاد لا يعلمه اكثر من
خمسه اشخاص ما يعني ان هناك سريه تامه
كبيره في يعني اداء وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه في اداء يعني هيئه الاركان
العامه الاوكرانيه وحتى في اداء المخابرات
الاوكرانيه هناك وضع عام يعلم الجميع ان
اوكرانيا في حاله حرب وان اي معلومه تخرج
الى العدو ستؤثر على وضع اوكرانيا في هذه
المرحله الحساسه خاصه قبل الهجوم المضاد
لذلك لا احد يستطيع تحديد معلومات خاصه من
يعني الجانب الاوكراني من الجيش الاوكراني
وحتى من الاداره الرئاسيه وهي ان كان هناك
قبل يومين او ثلاثه ايام طلب من وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه للاعلام مين عدم الخوض
والتحليل والحديث عن الهجوم مضاد والنقل
يعني الاس العسكري من الغرب من الدول
الغربيه الاوكرانيه شكرا لك من كيف كنت
معنا الصحفي محمد البابا تحياتي محمد
مشاهدينا الى تطورات الميدانيه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات الدفاع الجوي تعمل
على التعزيز امن حدودها الشماليه الغربيه
بعد انضمام فنلندا الى حلف الناتو وقال
قائد في قوات الدفاع الجوي انضمام فنلندا
الى الناتو واستعداد السويد للقيام بخطوه
مماثله هي خطوات تهدد حدود روسيا بدوره
قال مؤسس قوات فاجنر الروسيه
الف الى 400 الف جندي للهجوم المضاد
بانه لا يجب الاستحانه بالهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد وباي تحرك يمكن ان تنفذه القوات
الاوكرانيه في المرحله المقبله
نفت الحكومه الاسرائيليه صحه المعلومات
التي جاءت في وثيقه مسربه نسبت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه والتي تتحدث عن دعم
قيادينا في الموسى للتظاهرات المعارضه
للقانون بل لقانون تعديل النظام القضائي
وقال مكتب رئيس الوزراء في بيان ان
التقيره كاذب ولا اساس له من الصحه ورغم
ان البيانه لم ينفي صحه الوثيقه شكلا الا
انه شدد على بقاء الموساد بعيدا عن اي
نشاط سياسي في غضون ذلك مشاهدينا اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها فتحت تحقيقا
بخصوص الوثائق المسربه التي تهدد امن
البلاد
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
النيابه العامه السودانيه تقرر احاله
عناصر من الشرطه الى القضاء بتهمه قتل
اربعه متظاهرين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد بتزاول مع
مواصله الصين يومها الثالث من المناورات
العسكريه قرب جزيره تايوان اكدت بكين ان
طائرات تابعه لها تحمل ذخيره حيه اجرت
محاكاه لضربات قربه تايوان الاثنين حامره
ان وان حامله الطائرات شاندونغ شاركت ايضا
في المناورات الجاريه قرب الجزيره واوضح
الجيش الصيني في بيان له ان والاوضح ان
عده عده مقاتلات من طراز اتش سته كي تحمل
الذخيره استخدمت في هذه المناوره العسكريه
في حين افادت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
انها رصدت احدى عشره سفينه حربيه في محيط
الجزيره
وامننا القومي بطريقه رصينه وعقلانيه
ومدروسه في غضون ذلك ظلت وحدات دفاعنا
الجوي في حاله تاهب قصوى انهم يراقبون عن
كثب كل هدف محتمل ويستجيبون لحاله الطوارئ
وصفت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه ابحارا مدمر
الامريكي في بحر الصين الجنوبي بانه تواغل
غير قانوني وانها تراقب تحركاتها
وقالت البحريه الامريكيه ان ابحار مدمر
المزوده بصواريخ موجهه في بحر الصين
الجنوبي يهدف الى تاكيد الحقوق والحريات
الملاحيه واوضحت البحريه الامريكيه ان
العمليه التي قامت بها المدمره تتفق مع
القانون الدولي
[موسيقى]
مع تواصل صراع النفوذ بين واشنطن وبكين
كشفت تقارير غربي عن مخاوف هذا الاداره
الامريكيه من اسلحه الذكاء الاصطناعي
الصينيه وصل تحذيرات من دخول هذه التقنيه
سباقه تسلح بين الطرفين نتابع
تحديات كثيره فرضتها اسلحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي بين الصين والولايات المتحده
والتي تنذر بمنافسه شرسه عنوانها الصداره
للاذكى الصناعيه فمع دخولي هذه الاسلحه في
سباق التسلح بين بكين و واشنطن والذي احدث
نقله نوعيه في الاستراتيجيه الحربيه
الصينيه على المستوى التكتيكي والعسكري
كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه الجارديان عن قلق
امريكي من ان تستخدم بكين هذه التقنيه في
السعي وراء السلطه لتحل محل الولايات
المتحده باعتبارها القوه العظمى للذكاء
الاصطناعي في العالم من خلال اسلحه تقنيه
يمكن الاعتماد عليها في الحروب المستقبليه
فالجيش الصيني يسعى لتعميم مفاهيم حرب
الالات الذكيه او حرب الروبوتات المقاتله
المؤهله لتنفيذ العديد من العمليات
العسكريه من خلال روبوتات ومعد صغيره
مجهزه بمدافع رشاشه ونظم رؤيه الليليه
وصواريخ واجهزه استشعار للقيام بالعديد من
المهمات في الخطوط الاماميه وفقا لمعظم
المقاييس التي تعتمد عليها مؤسسه السياسه
الخارجيه في واشنطن فان احتمال وصول الصين
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي العام قبل الولايات
المتحده يبدو وكانه تهديد وجودي للهيمنه
الامريكيه فالتحركات الصين التي تسعى
لتكون مركزا للابتكار في مجال اسلحه
الذكاء الاصطناعي بحلول 2030 يمكن ان تؤدي
الى سباق تسلح جديد تغذيه الاجيال القديمه
من التكنولوجيا وسط مخاوف تتعلق بالخيارات
السريعه التي تتخذها الاسلحه الذكيه من
دون تدخل بشري
ومن دبي مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفيين الى
هاملي في هذه النشره ارسال واشنطن مدمره
امريكيه الى بحر الصين الجنوبي في هذا
التوقيت بالتاكيد يحمل رسائل هامه لبكين
كيف تلقفت بكير هذه الرسائل وما ابرز
التداعيات المتوقعه لهذه الخطوه الامريكيه
نعم اول شيء شكرا جزيلا لدعوتكم الكريمه
واهلا وسهلا للمشاهدينا الكرام في الحقيقه
ارسال الولايات المتحده مدمره عسكريه الى
البحرين الجنوبي اشاره خطيره او وايضا
يعني سيؤثر على العلاقات السلميه
الامريكيه المتوتره بشكل سلبي اول شيء حسب
تصريحات من قبل الوزاره الخارجيه دفاع
صينيه
الجيش الصيني تتابع او يتابع تحركات من
قبل المدمره الامريكيه بشكل دقيقه وثم كان
هناك
المراقبه السفن الحربيه الصينيه للمدمره
الولايات المتحده ولكن يعني
هناك لا مواجهه او اشتباكات بين
السفن الحربيه الصينيه وسفن والمدمره
الامريكيه وهذا توجد مواجهه سيدي الهام
لكن هذه الخطوه الامريكيه هي تعزز ما ذهب
اليه رئيس ليله الشؤون الخارجيه الامريك
يه في مجلس النواب الامريكيه الذي لوح
بارسال قوات امريكيه للدفاع عن تايوان هل
تعتقد اذا ان
واشنطن جاده في امكانيه الانخراط في صراع
عسكري مع الصين دفاعا عن تايوان
والله حتى الان لا اعتقد هناك
نيه بشكل دقيقه لارسال او نشره جنود
اوريكان على جزيره تايوان الصينيه او
نسيني يعني
بنسبه الى العبور المدمره الامريكيه في
بحر الصيني الجنوبي نعرف ان هذا الموقع
بعيد عن جزيره تايوان وفي الحقيقه الان في
الوقت نفسه هناك
مناورات او تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه للجيش
الصيني
بتتويق جزيره التايوان لذلك لا يمكن حتى
بالمدمر الامريكيه للاقتراب من موقع
المناورات وهذا امر مهم جدا لان اذا دخل
المدمر الامريكيه الى موقع المناورات هذا
بمعناها استفزازات عسكريه مباشره على
الجيش الصيني واكيد يكون هناك رد فعل
ضوئيه وشديده من الجيش الصيني لكن عندما
نتكلم عن الاوبو المدمره الامريكيه في بحر
الصين الجنوبيه هذا ايضا يعني اشاره
سياده الصينيه واعراضها
بالنسبه الى هذا النقطه سيكون هناك
تداعيات سلبيه جدا على العلاقات الثنائيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من دبي كنت معنا الصحفي
الصيني الهاملي تحيه سيدي الهام
والى ردود الفعل في الداخل الصيني
والتايواني اذ اختلفتعل المواطنين هناك ما
بين مؤيد ومعارض المناورات العسكريه التي
تجريها الصين في مضيق تايوان التي تزامرت
مع عوده رئيس التايوان عقب اجتماع في رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
ان الرغبه في ضم تايوان امر قريب للغايه
يبدو الامر كما لو كنت رايت مكانا ترغب في
الحصول عليه ثم تطالب بضمه هذا لا يبدو
معقولا معظم الناس ربما لا يخافون والسبب
الرئيسي هو ان الجميع يعتقدون ان الصين لن
تبدا حربا بالتاكيد
اعتقد ان هذه التدريبات العسكريه امر
طبيعي للغايه
لاننا نحتاج الى اظهار موقفنا وعلينا ايضا
اظهار قدرتنا للرد وتحديدا على الولايات
المتحده وليس على تايوان
مازلنا بحاجه الى رضع القوى الانفصاليه
الداعمه للاستقلال التايواني من منظور
الدبلوماسيه او الدولي فانه يظهر للعالم
ان التايوان جزء من الصين وهذا هو المغزى
الاساسي هناك طريقان مع القوه ستحتاج
دائما الى اضافه المزيد من القوه ولكن
التواصل بين المدنيين اخذ في الازدياد
ايضا على سبيل المثال مع اشياء مثل تيك
توك فانهم يزيدون من فهمهم للصين
طالبت كوريا الجنوبيه الولايات المتحده
باتخاذ اجراءات اللازمه بشان التجسس
المزعوم على كبار مسؤول امن الكوريين
فيصال ولم يستبعد مسؤول في القصر الرئاسي
في مشاركه الطرف ثالث في ازمه تثريب في
تسريب الوثائق السريه مؤكدا على ضروره
التحقيق في الامر وفق ما نقلت وكاله انباء
هاب الكوريه الجنوبيه
قالت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان وفدنا فنيا
سيتوجه الى السعوديه خلال ايام لبحث اعاده
فتح السفاره في الرياض وذلك للوقوف على
استعدادات اعاده فتح السفاره عقب اتفاق
على استئناف العلاقات السياسيه واعاده فتح
سفارتي البلدين وزار وفد فني سعودي ايران
السبت الماضي لمناقشه اليات فتح السفاره
في طهران والقنصليه في مشهد كشف صحيفه
بوليتيكو الامريكيه ان تلويح الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمراجعه علاقاتها مع
السعوديه العام الماضي بعد قرار اوبك بلس
تقليص انتاج النفط لم ينفذ ابدا وان
التصريحات في حينه كانت بسبب الحرج
الامريكي من قرار اوبك بلس
اكتوبر من عام 2022 اوبك بلس فاجات العالم
بخفض الانتاج بمعدل مليوني برميل يوميا
امريكا اعلنت معارضتها للخطوه والسعوديه
مضت قدما فيها اتهامات للرياض بالوقوف في
صف بوتين وتهديدات امريكيه بمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه
وبينما كانت الولايات المتحده تراجع
علاقتها مع السعوديه كما تقول مضت المملكه
في طريق مصالحها الامنيه والاقتصاديه رؤيه
2030 للامير محمد بن سلمان تطلبت استقرارا
سياسيا السعوديه وايران اتفقتا على اعاده
العلاقات بوساطه الصين الرغبه في استقرار
سياسي بالمنطقه يقود الى نماء اقتصادي
وتامين خطوط امداداتها الى العالم
[موسيقى]
نشاطنا مستمر المشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
اكثر من الف مستوطن اسرائيلي اقتحموا
باحات المسجد الاقصى على دفعات منذ صباح
هذا اليوم
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افادوا الرسول
العربيه بان اكثر من الف مستوطن اقتحم
مباحات المسجد الاقصى على دفعات وذلك تحت
حمايه الشرطه الاسرائيليه بينما يسود هدوء
حذر في البلده القديمه بالقدس ومحيط
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وكثافه قوات
الاسرائيليه نشرع عناصرها ووحداتها الخاصه
منذ الصباح في باحات المسجد الاقصى وعند
ابوابه لتامين اقتحامات المستوطنين خاصه
من ناحيه باب المغاربه زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيلي الا في طلب رئيس الوزراء
بنصادره الصلاحيات المتعلقه بالحرم القدسي
من الوزير
واكد العبيد عقب لقاء جمعه انه يدعم اي
اجراء امني تقدم عليه اسرائيل ردا على
الهجوم الصاروخي الاخير
في السودان مشاهدينا امر نيابه العامه
باحاله عناصر من الشرطه الى القضاء بتهمه
قتل اربعه محتاجين شاركوا في مظاهرات خلال
السنوات الاربع الماضيه حسبما افادت
الصحيفه السودان فيربيون ونقلت وسائل
الاعلام المحليه عن رئيس النيابه المختصه
بالنظر في دعاوى القتل والانتهاكات الطاهر
عبد الرحمن القول انه جرى احاله قضايا
المتهمين بعد اكتمال اجراءات التحقيق
وتوجيه اتهامات لهم بموجب الماده 130 من
القانون الجنائي الخاصه بالقتل العمد ولفت
رئيس النيابه العامه الى ان العقوبه بموجب
هذه الماده تصل الى الاعدام حال الادانه
وشيرا الى ان مدير عام الشرطه قام برفع
الحصانه عن عناصرها المحللين للقضاء
مراسل العربيه مشاهدينا يقول او يتحدث عن
اشتباكات بين قوات الاسرائيليه وشبان
الفلسطينيين في مخيم عقبه جبر باريحا
وسنوافيكم بمزيد من التفاصيل حولتها
بالعوده الى ملف السودان ويضورنا من
الخرطوم مراسله العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا
بك السالم وبدايه هل تاكدت هذه الانباء عن
احاله عناصر من الشرطه الى القضاء وما هي
ملابسات ايضا هذه القضايا المرفوعه ضدهم
اهلا احمد وبكل المشاهدين بدايه بكل تاكيد
هناك مصادر اكدت صحه هذه الاخبار والانباء
التي تحدثت عن هذه الحاله للقضاء
وهذا الامر تكرر في الفتره الماضيه كثيرا
مثل هذه القضايا القضايا المتعلقه بقتل
المتظاهرين خاصه وانه جاءت مناشدات كثيره
جدا
محليه تحدث عن المحتجين في الشارع الاحزاب
السياسيه كلها ناشدت
بانجاز هذه العداله فيما يتعلق بقتل
المتظاهرين بالاضافه الى المناشدات
الدوليه التي ظلت تتكرر في ملف حقوق
الانسان والانتهاكات التي تحدث في
التظاهرات او الاحتجاجات المتكرره التي
تدعو لها لجان المقاومه واحزاب سياسيه
اخرى كل هذا الامر ياتي في ظروف يمر بها
السولان سياسيا غير مستقره حتى الان هذا
ما يدفع الى هذه النقطه في مساله العداله
لانه تم من قبل قضايا مشابهه ولم يتم
انجاز ملف العداله لعدم وجود حكومه
مدنيه حتى اللحظه يعني كما تفضلت سالم
يعني هذه المطالبه بشكل كبير خاصه بعد
قرارات الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر التي
اعتدناها البرهان لكن ربما يبدان الوقت
لها ما نسع نعود اليك ربما في سياق نشاط
المقبل الاستكمال الحديث حول هذا الموضوع
شكرا لك من الخرطوم على مؤسسه العربيه
سالم الهاشمي
لم تمنع الحرب والمعارك مسلميه من احياء
طقوسهم الدينيه في شهر رمضان فرغم الاوضاع
الصعبه التي يعيشونها نزاعات العسكريه بين
روسيا واوكرانيا والقصف المتبادل بينهما
الا انهم ينتقدون الى المدن الامنه لاقامه
موائد الرحمن واداء صلواتهم زميلنا رائد
الاغبر اعد لنا التقرير التالي نتابعه
[موسيقى]
توجهنا الى مدينه مريوبل لتغطيه تجمع
مسلمي مقاطعه دانياتك في مسجد المدينه
الكبير
المسلمون مما يقطنون مدينه دانيتك يسافرون
الى ماريوبل لاداء الصلاه في يوم الجمعه
وللمشاركه في موائد الرحمن حيث ان مساجدهم
قريبه من مناطق النزاع في الاحياء الغربيه
من العاصمه لا تزال مدينه ماريوبل اكثر
امنا من غيرها من المدن في مقاطعه دانياتك
كونها تقع على بعد مسافه من قواعد القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تقصف مدن الموالين لروسيا
ذلك ما اتاح للمسلمين هنا اقامه طقوسهم
الدينيه في شهر رمضان الفضيل شراب
خلال اليومين الماضيين كان الافطار في
مدينه مكيفكا واليوم نفطر في ماريوبل وغدا
ان شاء الله في غورلفكا وبعده في شختار
شريحه كبيره من العاملين في قطاع البناء
هم من المسلمين ذوي الاصول الاسيويه وقد
رحلوا الى هذه المناطق للمشاركه في اعاده
اعمار المدينه
هنا اوضاع حربيه لذلك يتوجب علينا التواجد
بقرب اخوتنا في الدين من المسلمين ويجب
علينا مساعدتهم وتقديم الدعم لهم وفي
الدرجه الاولى الدعم الروحاني هنا في مسجد
ماريوبل الكبير يجتمع المسلمون الروس
لاحياء طقوسهم الدينيه على موائد الرحمن
التي قامت على انشائها ومدها الهيئه
العامه للمسلمين في مقاطعه دانيسك
يقدم الطعام في شهر رمضان الفضيل لزائري
المسجد ويجتمع المسلمون هنا في وقت
الافطار على اختلاف منابتهم ومن جميع
انحاء الاقليم لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد
الاغبر ماريوبل
عصير زبيب العنب الاسود المجفف يكادو لا
يفارق المائده الرمضانيه في معظم مدن
العراق سيما موائد سكان المحافظات شمال
العراق الا ان الموصليين يصنعونه بطريقه
مختلفه ساهمت في زياده الطلب عليه
على الرغم من ان شربت الزبيب يصنع في اغلب
المحافظات العراقيه الا انه يتميز في
صناعته بمدينه الموصل بطعم مختلف عن
المناطق الاخرى فطريقته تحضيره تمر بمرحله
الحج وهي فصل الحبوب او البزور على العنب
الاسود المجفف هذا فضلا عن اضافته عشبه
النعناع الى الخلطه وذلك بعد غسله ونقعه
لاربعه وعشرين ساعه
طريقه الزبيب عندنا الزبيب او بالبدايه
نغسله
وشوايه بنغسلهم الاتربه والشوائب نرجع
نحلجه بالماكينه مال حليج ونرجع نخليه
الاكياس اكياس
وترجعوا اسبابه وانتشار عصير الزبيب في
المائده الرمضانيه الموصليه وكذلك سكان
المحافظات الاخرى في اقليم كردستان العراق
الى تراجع زراعه النخيل على مر العصور في
هذه المناطق بسبب الطقس البارد تستبدل
التمور بعصير الزبيب المجفف الذي ذاع صيته
وبات جزءا اساسيا للمائده العراقيه
لاعتقاد الصائمين انه يعوض السكريات التي
يفقدها جسم صائم شربه الزبيبلو اهميه
كبيره بالعد الصائمين بالموصل لان يحتوي
على فوائد كثيره يعني نحن كسائمين نشربه
بالطاقه خلينا نقاوم فتره الصيام الطويله
اللي
عشناها
يعني يحتوي على السكريات
الطاقه لهذا نعتبرك شربه مفضل عندنا نحن
كسائمين بالموصل وتحصلوا العائلات والمحل
التجاريه المختصه بصناعه عصير الزبيب على
امدادات الزبيب محليا حيث تاتي كميات
كبيره منه من جبال كردستان العراق القريبه
من الموصل بالاضافه الى بساتين العنب
المنتشره في بعض المحافظات العراقيه
الاخرى احمد الحمداني العربيه اربيل
[موسيقى]
الاعمار الخليجيه في شهر رمضان هذا العام
نافست بقوه وحققت نجاحا مهما حيث ظهرت
افكار مختلفه وتم طرح قصص جديده دارت في
جغرافيه الخليج او حتى خارجه مقدمه
الحكايات الملفته تستحق التوقف عندها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سيارتي الروز رايس والله ما تردها والله
[موسيقى]
مرحبا لم يكن مسلسل طاش ما طاش جماهيريه
مطالب بالعوده بجديد الجمهور كان مكتفي
مبدئيا بفكره عوده ثنائيه ناصر القصبي
وعبد الله السدحان للعمل ليس ذلك وحسب
والعوده بعض النجوم ممن كانوا مبتعدين
خاصه الجراح وفهد الحيان وغيرها الا انه
كان ينتظر ان يعود العمل بقصص وحكايه
وقضايا تشبه ما يعيش اليوم وواقع مختلف
تماما بالطبع عن الماضي وهو ما كان فريق
العمل ليحرص عليه طوال فتره التحذير يعني
هذا اكثر شيء يشغلنا انك انت شلون شلون
ترجع الجو
العام حق طاش شخصيات بافكار البسيطه هذا
اكثر شيء كان شاغلنا
يعني واتوقع ان حنا يعني
المسنع هذا الجو يعني
رحنا الجو
خفيف
حاولنا نركز على الجو الشعبي
ولا اشرك العديد من النجوم والشباب
البارزين على الساحه الان بينما ذهب الى
مواقع تصوير في كل ارجاء الرياض وهو امر
اسعد الجمهور جدا الذي يتابع بحب واهتمام
وينتظر المزيد انا سعدت بكثير من الحلقات
اللي قدمناها نعم احنا قعدنا واخذنا
واعطينا في ورشه النص انا سعيد بالشخصيات
اللي قدمتها وكذلك سعيد بالشخصيات اللي
قدمها ناصر والزملاء اللي شاركونا هذا
العمل
العمل هذا عمل سهل سهل صعب ماني عارف اقول
كنت اقول انا كاني في حلم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وقبل ختام هذه النشره نذكر بابرز العناوين
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تكشف ان دفاعات
اوكرانيا لن تتحمل القصف الروسيه بيساوي
نقص الذخيره
تجري مناورات بذخيره حيه قربه وترفض ارسال
واشنطن مدمره الى بحر الصين الجنوبي
وفد فني الايراني يتوجه الى الرياض خلال
ايام لمواصله استعدادات اعاده فتح السفاره
الايرانيه
اكثر من 1500 مستوطن اسرائيلي اقتحم مباحث
مسجد الاقصى على دفعات منذ صباح اليوم
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
انسانيه والوثائق والتقارير الاخباريه لا
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات